from taylor to rihanna we're celebrating
the artist hitting all the high notes in
2021 welcome to entertainment tonight
let's start with the california girl
turning las vegas into her ultimate
playground miss katy perry now listen
kev it all goes down tonight and katie
gave matt coyne a sneak peek
the residencies in vegas seem to be
super hot right now what are adele will
be there she's my neighbor at home
she'll be my neighbor in vegas we'll
carpool
[Music]
channeling elvis and promising a
larger-than-life show katie's waking up
in vegas for her brand new residency and
we have all the behind the scenes
secrets
i'm a doll in the show and so we're in
different sets that are like 10 times
the size of me so it's kind of like
honey i shrunk the kids i love it one of
my favorite movies meets
pee-wee's playhouse also one of my
favorite movies
and
you know
maybe with a little cbd
[Music]
this show is really the most
concentrated version of me it is
jam-packed hit after hit after hit
basically we went down the streaming
playlist and said okay what are people
listening to the top 20 and that's our
set list
[Music]
katy perry play opens today at the
theater at resorts world in las vegas
the show took a year and a half of
planning with the help of katie's
creative directors ant and ash from the
square division there is one scene that
requires dancing mushrooms
see
it's our drinks over here um and
you know what's funny about that is i
didn't even ask for this but they're
putting in some contraption in these
dancing mushrooms
to make them
spore
right right yes yeah you're going to
check the dancing mushrooms the other
ones oh the scenic mushrooms so we sent
us a video a very long time ago and it
was just mushroom sporing at night i
watched this documentary called
fantastic fungi and now here i am
how do we feel about rehearsals so far
these guys have been with me probably
through my worst of times and they're
experiencing me in a better place more
balanced place after having you know my
child and my partner and just finding
that balance in life when i'm rehearsing
i always have a kind of a dummy mic i
used to just like throw it when i
couldn't like get a piece of
choreography and like it wasn't it
wasn't like that it was like
or anything but this mic that we have
now the new one has only been thrown
once and it was a very light throw if
you can you know handle me at my worst
you can have me at my best also betting
big with katie a good friend and fellow
idol judge luke bryant he kicks off his
vegas residency at resorts world in
february
yeah that's my kind of night
but 2021 was a big year for luke for
starters he turned 45 in july i saw like
the rock on instagram and he was like 44
and his shirt off and i'm like
yeah i'm not i'm a little lace from the
rock look do not sell yourself shortly
doing the jockey thing man
underwear ready 24 7. help me out dwayne
give me some tips baby
he may not have the rox muscles but the
country star's got some impressive
titles on his resume like cma host and
acm entertainer of the year luke bryan
i'm in l.a oh my god y'all got me
and when we hung out with luke on his
tour bus he was celebrating the 10-year
anniversary of his breakout hit country
girl shake it for me
when you think of that song what does it
mean to your career well it means good
old-fashioned fun it sent my career to
[Music]
another level it told the world
well a this guy's here
to just have fun
but luke's rise to fame wasn't without
tragedies his brother died in a car
accident his sister passed away
unexpectedly and his brother-in-law had
a fatal heart attack luke let his fans
in on all of it in the five-part
docu-series luke bryant my dirt bro
diary on imdb tv people when they walk
up to me on the street and they're like
hey man you know you really inspire us
if we can inspire them
and and and help them
dust themselves off so that's what this
thing
really is about
luke has had quite a year and it
couldn't happen to a better guy
now i'm here at madame tussauds new york
in times square rihanna had a lot of big
moments in this city it was also the
year she became the only girl
entertainer to hit billionaire boss
status
[Music]
i've been more busy in quarantine than
ever before the journey has been
incredible it's
a lot of hard work
yep all that work paid off this year
ribry became a self-made billionaire
forbes estimates her worth at a
staggering of 1.7 billion dollars most
of rhianna's fortune comes not from
music but her lifestyle brands what are
you involved with the process and the
designing elements of things oh my god
i'm
too involved i want a break and riri
also took a relationship with boyfriend
asap rocky to the next level they made
their red carpet debut as a couple on
the steps of the met gala
[Applause]
you guys are making a red carpet
official
we're all ready together
riri was definitely busy and had her own
new york red carpet career nine days
later
[Music]
savage xfenty show volume 3 is streaming
now on amazon prime video by the numbers
there are 156 models seven performers
and one steamy choreographed scene
featuring you darling
stevie i was like it was steamy read
that was some sexy choreography
not easy in a corset let me just say
that much
as for new music rihanna's last album
was in 2016 and fans are hoping for a
collab with asap
love to see you so happy but honey what
collaboration do you all have next we'd
love to see the two of you collaborate
personally proof now you're asking my
personal favorite
you know i am says
i tried i tried
and look when it comes to new music i
know ree is a busy woman but michelle
can we get a single or something am i
right you are right just a little note
just a mm or do re me and ella ella ella
or something like that thank you rachel
meanwhile taylor swift couldn't stop
releasing music in 2021 and let me tell
you the swifties
they were here for it
[Music]
i love seeing swifties right because
there's nothing like them you're giving
them red your version and i know it's
been really important for you to own
your own music what was it like going
back and visiting that era and doing it
all over again it was an amazing
experience and this was something that
started out as a really hard thing i
went through
the fans are the people saying to me
over and over again we want to listen to
your versions so if they hadn't done
that i don't think i'd be having this
amazing exciting experience red taylor's
version is the second re-recording of
her iconic early albums
[Music]
while the 2012 red album contained 16
tracks taylor's version has 30 including
new collaborations with phoebe bridgers
chris stapleton and longtime friend ed
sheeran
she is a very very good friend of mine
we're both the same age we both write
songs it's a pleasure knowing her we
hang out all the time and he's a
wonderful wonderful friend
taylor's other friend blake lively
directed her recent music video i bet
you think about me where she walks down
the aisle with miles teller
blake and husband ryan reynolds were
also part of swiftkey's snl squad
[Music]
taylor took to the stage and unleashed a
passionate 10-minute performance of all
too well
backstage ryan snapped this photo of
taylor with bow and yang and sadie sink
blake's foot even made a cameo also
supporting taylor og besties selena
gomez
my bestie
taylor who recently celebrated her 32nd
birthday with friends is clearly in a
much better place than her red breakup
ballad day cause i knew you were in
trouble when you walked in
she's head over heels with boyfriend of
five years british actor joe alwyn the
red album in its entirety was sort of
like a heartbroken person right so what
would you then say to that taylor who
wrote all those songs back
their fans are singing out there
there's hundreds of people singing the
words
and by the way i like groan taylor's
version of red better than i did younger
taylor's version just very very good
she's had some life experiences